jours ce n'est pas simplement un nouveau
modèle que présente aujourd'hui la régie
renault
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison que
nous avons choisi d'en faire le premier
sujet d'actualité de ce lundi
car l'automobile est un élément
essentiel de notre société
aujourd'hui en effet renault présente
donc l'espace un véhicule à mi chemin
entre la camionnette et la berline
traditionnelle une voiture salon une
voiture qui n'est pas simplement fait
pour aller d'un point à un autre
mais pour y vivre pendant le voyage
comme à l'intérieur d'un appartement
roulant jean claude renard une japonaise
non une renault espace conçu en
collaboration avec matra nivan ni
autobus ni berline classique c'est une
berline monocorps où tout est conçu pour
que les passagers puissent aménager
l'espace habitable à l'orgue
mais ne vous y trompez pas la renault
espace et rapide 175 kilomètres/heure
disponible en deux versions c'est une
neuf chevaux pour le fisc est une
cliente raisonnable pour le pompiste
le constructeur annonce qu'elle consomme
en moyenne 8 litres cette hausse en
l'espace donc une voiture ni trop haute
ahmed 66 ni trop longue cape may 25 en
fait un véhicule de loisirs ce n'est pas
un camping car maison pommes puis y
habiter le plancher plat autorise de
nombreuses combinaisons à partir de
trois rangées de sièges amovibles et
modulable inclinable pivotant équipés de
tablettes comme dans les avions
ils rendent au passage et leur liberté
mais me direz-vous pour quel prix
l'espace existe en deux versions 2000 gt
s 96 mille francs et 2000 t es ce sens
8500 francs
celle ci est une télé se met avec
beaucoup d'options de toit ouvrant
peinture métallisée deux sièges
supplémentaires à l'arrière qui sont en
option et la radio ce qui porte son prix
à 123 1740 francs l'espace sera
disponible à partir du 15 juin renault
compte en produire dix mille ans
maintenant et lancera à partir d'octobre
deux versions turbo diesel